alors bonjour à tous donc effectivement
je m'appelle arthur puiu
l'utc de 2014 donc il ya pas si
longtemps j'étais souvent par là le
samedi matin est donc aujourd'hui je
vais vous parler principalement de
paiement parce que j'ai passé les
dernières années j'ai passé les
dernières années en fait à faire pas mal
de paiement est plus un peu plus
largement que le paiement de comment on
peut acheter en un clin d'oeil du coup
puisque c'est le thème de cette journée
alors pour vous remettre juste un petit
peu de contexte que pour ceux qui
connaissent pas toute l'histoire sans
non plus y passer trois heures non quand
je fais comme ça donc je vous mets une
petite photo voilà avec donc thomas qui
est sur la gauche et mathieu de l'autre
côté
donc les deux autres utc un avec qui on
a monté le projet peyote donc payé
c'était en 2012 et comme ça à l'air
d'être très bien rester dans les esprits
vu l'introduction px on l'a clan c'est
au foyer étudiants de l'utc
ça a été le premier le premier endroit
où on l'utilisé et c'était réservé en
fait au début il y avait déjà un système
de paiement par carte adulte et c'est au
niveau du foyer et on s'est dit qu'on
voulait améliorer ce système qu'on
voulait étendre ce système on a commencé
par par installer donc du coup cette
nouvelle version de notre logiciel au
foyer et puis ensuite on l'a étendu
auprès d'autres associations donc on
avait quand même conçu le système avec
ça en tête
le but c'était que d'autres associations
leur école puisse utiliser le même
système de compte que ce soit pour payer
en ligne pour faire de la billetterie
pour commander des posters ou bien pour
payer physiquement donc avec la carte
comme on le faisait déjà dans le foyer
donc été un lieu fixe mais également
avec et c'est ça qui est en photo des
petits terminaux mobiles qu'on appelait
les pays de spawn et du coup c'est
terminé on les avait achetés donc
c'était vachement sympa parce que
c'était des terminaux en fait cédé
smartphone classique donc ça a été très
facile à mettre en place à du tc et du
coup ça nous permettait d'encaisser un
peu partout pour un peu n'importe quoi
et du coup ça tourne toujours
aujourd'hui est une fonctionnalité je
vais je vais la cité qui avait il y
avait beaucoup plu aux étudiants à
l'époque j'ai la city tout de suite et
puis on en reparlera après à une autre
échelle et que vous connaissez tous c
est bien sûr le virement à un ami donc
qui permet aux étudiants de se
transférer de l'argent entre eux
pour transférer de l'argent entre eux
pour régler un peu tout et n'importe
quoi en fait donc ça c'était en 2012
donc on va accélérer jusqu'à 2015
donc ça c'était 2015 on s'est retrouvé
avec les deux autres même personne et
puis quelques quelques quelques
personnes en plus qui qui nous ont en
fait récupéré pour nous propulser dans
l' aventure de l'événement et on se
retrouve aux vieilles charrues donc aux
vieilles charrues le plus grand festival
de france sont imposés 90 milles
bracelet avec exactement la même techno
que ce qu'on avait réfléchi pour payer
et on avait des gens qui allaient payer
au bar alors pas qu'aux bars étaient
nourriture barres merchandising etc
mais avec le même principe à me reste
les cons précharge et où on va on va
dépenser juste en présentant le bracelet
est en fait ça ça a très bien fonctionné
ça a très bien fonctionné sur et vielles
charrues sur plein d'autres festivals on
a fait 200 festival cette année
et pas que des festivals et ça plaît
beaucoup aux organisateurs bien sûr
parce que du coup ça supprime en fait la
circulation des espèces dans le festival
mais pas que en fait ça plaît aussi au
public c'est à dire que le public a
priori on va dire ah oui mais bon on
enregistre tous nos mouvements
le bar on paye plus avec les espèces
alors que c'était millions c'est plus
cohérent n'a globalement les retours
qu'on a du public c'est des études qui
sont assez scientifique qui sont faits
par des cabinets spécialisés
c'est que le public il aime bien ça en
fait alors pourquoi ce après au public
c'est un peu la question à laquelle je
vais je vais essayer de répondre et ça a
un rapport avec le thème du jour puisque
effectivement aujourd'hui alors j'ai pas
remis rome un clin d'oeil mais on vit
dans un monde à qui est toujours plus
rapide un monde en un clin d'oeil
effectivement en 2010 est globalement
les gens le public ils ont plus envie
d'attendre ils ont internet avec
internet on a tout leur formation à
portée de main alors là je pourrais je
pourrais vous parler très longtemps de
choses très technique mais je vais je
vais faire assez simple je vais prendre
un exemple qui est vraiment l'exemple de
base
je suis allait revérifier les données
hier soir en finissant la présentation
bien sûr et donc du coup quand vous
envoyez une lettre en nouvelle zélande
il ya quelques années on avait la poste
qui passait hors jeu pas s'il y avait
des avions direct qui allait en nouvelle
zélande
je pense que c'est rare encore
aujourd'hui mais globalement on va dire
qu'il faut quelques jours pour envoyer
une lettre là bas et quelques jours et
que ça revienne quand on n'avait pas les
avions effectivement alors là on parlait
plutôt de moi parce qu'on faisait du
bateau ont traversé la planète
le nouvel an c'est vraiment le l'opposé
le plus complet je pense qu'on peut pas
trouver beaucoup plus loin aujourd'hui
donc gg checker le site internet d'un
opérateur en nouvelle zélande un
opérateur de téléphonie il faut 300
millisecondes pour aller là-bas donc
sans fin 300 millisecondes pour faire un
aller-retour
c'est le ping pour ceux qui connaissent
300 millisecondes de ping c'est beaucoup
mais c'est quand même rien du tout pour
aller jusqu'à la nouvelle zélande et ça
équivaut à deux clins d'oeil pour
l'aller 1 pour le retour
voilà ça c'était la partie un peu à
chiffrer du coup aujourd'hui on a des
applications de messagerie instantanée
donc qui ont d'instantanés le nom c'est
à dire que les gens reçoivent tout de
suite les messages mais en fait au delà
de ça on constate ça vous l'avez vu donc
ça a commencé
ça commence et puis en fait aujourd'hui
elles le font tout mais les api de
messagerie instantanée elles vont vous
dire aujourd'hui le message a été reçue
donc arthur avec votre mère arthur a
reçu le message et après pire encore
arthur a lu le message
alors ça c'est horrible parce que du
coup on n'ose plus ouvrir les messages
et en fait quand on l'a ouvert on sait
que la personne c'est qu'on avait lu lé
qu'on a vu le message est en fait du
coup on se sent obligé de répondre tout
de suite c'est souvent ça en fait un qui
font ça c'est juste que du coup on se
dit bon ben voila si je réponds pas de
façon c'est un peu
c'est un peu la honte ou où je vais me
faire harceler du coup je réponds tout
de suite comme ça c'est fait et du coup
l'autre par ailleurs soit pile ou pas du
coup en fait on se retrouve à échanger
en permanence pour tout et n'importe
quoi et en fait avec à la fois des
technologies qui permettent d'aller plus
vite qui permettent de communiquer
beaucoup plus rapidement mais qui en
plus alors après il ya des raisons et à
des raisons business surtout ce qu'ils
appellent le temps d'écran c'est à dire
que les grosses les grosses entreprises
sur internet ont intérêt à ce que vous
passiez le plus de temps possible dans
leur service bien sûr et donc du coup
pour que vous soyez tout le temps dans
l'appli on va faire en sorte que de
favoriser cet échange instantanée qui
change vraiment la façon dont on a
d'interagir avec les gens moi l'exemple
que je prends toujours avant c'est quand
on allait chez quelqu'un avant à paris
on pensait à lui demandé avant d'y aller
le code de chez lui là aujourd'hui on
ferait toujours un message quand on est
en bas
jamais jamais plus tôt donc ça du coup
voilà ça c'est tout ce qui est
communication donc c'est assez virtuel
physiquement alors là on est en plein
dans la période de noël
donc c'est assez pertinent en plus de
discuter de ça physiquement c'est pareil
c'est à dire que les grands marchands de
dix commerces
ils sont un peu dans une course et a des
tonnes de start up qui se développe là
dedans
donc je dis commerce ça va être sur des
achats de produits de cadeau de noël
mais c'est pareil avec les livraisons de
nourriture
le but aujourd'hui c'est pas seulement
de pouvoir livrer quelque chose et
encore moins n'importe où parce que du
coup il ya des nouveaux services qui
apparaissent qui sont vraiment focalisé
sur certaines villes qui sont
disponibles que dans certaines villes
ces cas pour les tout ce qui est
transport mais aussi sur sur certains
services de livraison et où on a une
livraison du coup on a eu la livraison
au lendemain on a eu la livraison le
soir et l'a récemment amazon du coup a
sorti un service où il livre en une
heure alors c'est c'est franchement c on
ne devient très vite accroît ce à quoi
les jeux j'ai déjà commandé un cadeau
sexy pour le soir même il est arrivé en
une heure c'est vrai que c'est très
pratique quand vraiment s'y prend au
dernier moment et ce qui est notable là
dedans c'est que du coup les gens ont
envie de d'avoir le envie d'avoir les
produits plus vite en fait à partir du
moment où on va ya voir l'acte d'achat
et je vais reparler d'actes d'achat
après à partir du moment où j'ai dit je
souhaite acheter
ce téléphone là je le veux tout de suite
maintenant c'est s'est tout de suite ou
sinon ce sera trop tard quoi donc du
coup les gens on constate sont prêts à
payer un supplément pour être livrées
immédiatement et ça coûte ça coûte super
cher des services qui kiffent qui livre
en temps réel et ils font ça c'est pas
forcément des frais de livraison s'est
globalement ils vont avoir des prix qui
sont un peu au dessus
et ça du coup c'est ça montre qu'il ya
vraiment une grosse grosse demande sur
des services qui livrent au plus vite
donc du coup pour pouvoir livrer
rapidement pour pouvoir acheter plus
rapidement en fait globalement on a
besoin de payer plus rapidement
donc c'est là que il ya de la
technologie de paiement
pierre entre en jeu et du coup comment
est ce qu'on peut faire un peu déformé
le monsieur comme risque on peut faire
pour pour payer plus rapidement et donc
du coup le moyen de paiement
traditionnels bien sûr historique c'est
les espèces je peux trouver certaines y
joue pas donc les espèces globalement je
pense que vous en utilisez encore un peu
tous personnellement de mon côté je
retire très très rarement de l'argent et
je ne m'en porte pas plus mal
il ya des pays en fait qui qui ont
décidé de sortir d'un fonctionnement
avec des espèces donc il ya des raisons
diverses et variées pour ça donc il ya
des raisons qui vont être assez pratique
donc de moderniser en fait là le
paiement donc pour forcer le paiement
avec modernise dans le pays
ils vont dire voilà on a un objectif qui
est d'ici 2025 réduire les paiements en
espèce de 50% et donc des pays comme ça
il y en a en europe la suède par exemple
donc la suède qui a une grosse volonté
de tuer en fait le la monnaie est
aujourd'hui du coup ils n'ont plus que
de 20% des transactions en magasin donc
façon sur internet
toutes les transactions j'ai envie de
dire les achats de maisons les tout ce
qui est grosse opération de façon ça se
fait déjà 100 espèces mais ce qui compte
vraiment c'est ce qui reste en fait en
magasin donc les transactions physiques
et du coup ils ont ils leur reste plus
que 20 % des opérations qui se font en
espèces sur le sur les points de vente
physiques alors là il ya un truc qui est
très important et du coup là je fais
référence à payer 800 corps dont on
parlait tout à l'heure et est en fait
donc du coup donc au niveau des
virements à un ami donc du coup en suède
quand le gouvernement a annoncé en fait
ce souhait de sortir des espèces ils ont
sorti un moyen de paiement entre
particuliers qui s'appelle switch est en
gros je vais mettre le numéro de
téléphone de quelqu'un je veux dire lui
envoie 1 30 euro est en fait moi j'ai un
compte switch qui est connecté à mon
téléphone aussi ça prend 30 euros sur
mon compte ça lui envoie 30 euros il
reçoit une notification tout de suite
alors c'est vrai que chez nous pour
faire des virements
entre les comptes mais c'est trop long
en fait aujourd'hui pour qu'on puisse se
dire ok je te paye une bière et deux
mois tout en dribbles il ajoute il ya
des banques qui envoie un courrier chez
les gens pourront rentrer le code après
fin c'est donc c'est il ya encore
beaucoup de travail là dessus et du coup
switch en suède ça a permis de vraiment
poussé en fait ceux de favoriser en fait
la disparition des espèces puisque du
coup ça ça permet ça se dit à cet
échange qui est très important qui le
transfert d'argent entre particuliers
est en fait ça en vrai quand on était
quand on travaillait sur paint c'était
pas forcément une fonctionnalité salon
c'était une idée comme ça qu'on avait eu
un moment le truc était pas plus
réfléchie que ça nous on se rend compte
qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce genre de
fonctionnalités en fait qui fait que du
coup ça peut vraiment prendre place dans
le quotidien des gens parce qu'en fait
il ya toutes ces petites transactions
qui qu'il faut qu'il faut arriver à
couvrir est alors un autre exemple qui
est assez marrant que j'ai vu sur switch
donc le système de transfert en
particulier en suède c'est que il donne
l exemple de la quête dans les églises
et là effectivement on va pas faire
passer des tpe dans l'église mais du
coup ce qu'ils font c'est qu'ils
affichent un numéro de téléphone est en
fait les gens font un transfert comme ça
sur le numéro de téléphone directement
et là on voit ils ont un peu détourné le
truc mais en fait ça permet de récupérer
de récupérer encore encore d'autres
paiements et petit à petit sortir
complètement de de ces fameuses espèces
il ya d'autres pays qui ont souhaité
qu'ils ont ce qu'ils ont annoncé en fait
vouloir sortir des espèces un autre si
vous si c'est un sujet qui vous
intéresse que vous pourrez les suivre
qui est l'inde donc en inde qui a quand
même 1,3 milliard d'habitants
aujourd'hui donc c'est quand même un
assez gros pays
le gouvernement a annoncé qu'ils
souhaitaient sortir en fait à terme d'un
modèle avec des espèces donc c'est pas
facile pour l'instant ça se passe pas
très bien ça avance bien mais c'est pas
ils vont avoir du mal à tenir tous les
objectifs mais en tout cas c'est un
exemple qui est très intéressant a
assité alors ça c'était pour le paiement
physique
enfin ça c'était la partie du coup
vraiment introduction du cash laisse
donc ce qu'on appelle cash laisse du
coup ça va être vraiment
le paiement sans espèces c'est ce que ça
veut dire littéralement et du coup au
niveau du paiement physique qu'est ce
qu'on a comme moyen et
de faire du cash laisse le moyen
principal c'est la carte bancaire la
carte bancaire je pense que tout le
monde en a une
aujourd'hui enfin des transactions de
base en carte bancaire on va faire un
code ça prend un peu de temps et du coup
les ce qu'ils ont trouvé c'est le
paiement sans contact qui permet
d'accélérer la transaction en gros ça va
être la première façon de vraiment
accélérer les transactions bancaires de
dons qui est du coup le ce paiement par
carte bancaire
avec ou sans contact on a aussi des
solutions de paiement mobile du coup
donc qui peuvent être soit basée sur la
carte bancaire soit être un truc
complètement à part de la carte bancaire
donc on a un portefeuille en fait on a
un système où on utilise le téléphone
pour s'identifier et on relie notre
carte bancaire derrière et donc en fait
tout ça donc ça va être un moyen de
faire des transactions de manière assez
standard et puis après on a bien sûr une
troisième option qui est utilisable dans
certains milieux vraiment spécifique qui
va être d'avoir un support dédié donc
c'est ce qu'ont à l'utc par exemple avec
la carte étudiante qui sert de qui sert
en fait de support pour s'identifier à
aller chercher dans son compte qu'on a
préchargé sur internet aujourd'hui on
utilise majoritairement la carte
bancaire aussi sauf que bon vous trouvez
peut-être que recopier le code de votre
carte bancaire à chaque fois c'est pas
très moderne
en fait c'est un truc qui est assez
historique c'est à dire que
traditionnellement historiquement pour
en identifier les cartes bancaires avec
un numéro aujourd'hui on utilise
toujours ça sur internet mais de plus en
plus on voit des services se développer
donc quelques paypal mais qui commence
aussi à avoir des concurrents en france
où des concurrents qui sont portées par
les par les réseaux de cartes bancaires
directement
et qui permettent en fait du coup de
faire des autorisations de transactions
plutôt que de donner notre carte
bancaire etc après la personne peut en
faire ce qu'elle veut et la réutiliser
autant de fois qu'elle veut on va juste
avoir un compte dans lequel on a mis la
carte bancaire qui est protégé et qui va
délivrer une autorisation de
transactions donc ça c'est sur internet
sur internet avec ce système on a un
truc qui est super important aussi qui
est le fait de pouvoir enregistrer sa
carte bancaire et ça du coup dans ma
troisième partie ça va ça va vraiment
prendre son sens on va enregistrer sa
carte bancaire
et après on va pouvoir faire des
transactions a posteriori donc en
débitant sur la carte bancaire
donc là du coup on a vu qu'il y avait on
a vu qu'il y avait effectivement des
moyens en fait de de supprimer de
réduire les espèces alors le but en fait
en vrai c'est pas forcément de supprimer
les espèces mais le but c'est de
faciliter le paiement et donc du coût en
utilisant des moyens de paiement
numérique c'est quand même plus pratique
quand on est dans un bar en train de
faire la queue et qu'on se rend compte
qu'on a plus d'espèces de se dire je
vais pouvoir payer avec ma carte plutôt
que de sortir de là que aller faire la
queue aux distributeurs et revenir
refaire la queue au bar quoi on est en
en 2017 on est capable de pouvoir
dépenser tout l'argent qu'on a sur son
compte en banque si on veut
et ne pas ne pas aller faire des allers
retours de retirer même recharger la
carte ce qu'on fait pour payer
c'est ce qu'on fait sur des sur des
supports très payer c'est une étape qui
pourrait à terme disparaître si on veut
quoi si on veut simplifier vraiment le
paiement et du coup comment en fait et
ce qu'on pourrait alors c'est une
c'est une réflexion à laquelle je suis
arrivé en fait en réfléchissant
réfléchissions à ce sujet comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait arriver à vraiment
supprimer en fait l'étape du paiement
complètement lorsque l'on veut récupérer
un objet alors en fait c'est déjà il ya
une option qui consiste à tout faire
gratuitement
donc c'était un peu avant qui est la
monnaie
globalement on peut s'inspirer un peu de
ce qui se fait ce qui s'est fait au
niveau de la musique
il ya eu beaucoup de téléchargement
illégal à un moment quand internet est
arrivé ensuite les il ya des systèmes
qui sont arrivés où on pouvait acheter
des morceaux
alors bon il ya eu des grosses
industries qui entoure et a su notamment
itunes mais c'est pas forcément des
systèmes qui ont été vraiment vraiment
démocratiser et puis après il ya ce
qu'on a aujourd'hui
donc aujourd'hui la musique la plupart
des gens ils ont un abonnement à un
système qui permet d'écouter de la
musique en illimité donc on va payer une
fois on va payer enfin une fois où tous
les mois une somme fixe et peu importe
qu'on consomme ça c'est du coup les
systèmes par abonnement donc ça marche
pour la musique ça marche pour les films
aussi donc c'était pareil avant d'aller
louer des dvd en bas de la rue ça marche
pour les films il ya ticketmaster c'est
assez intéressant qui fait ça pour des
concerts aussi c'est à dire que ils ont
sorti aux états unis
un parce que vous achetez vous payer ça
tous les mois et vous pouvez aller à
tous les concerts à tous les concerts
que vous voulez en fait qui sont
produits par par ce producteur on ne
voit ça aussi au niveau des transports
tu es donc la sncf ils ont sorti un
abonnement pour les qui est surtout à
destination des jeunes aujourd'hui mais
en gros c'est un moyen d'expérimenter
sur une population sur une population
réduite un système où on paye à un truc
fixe et après on peut prendre à peu près
tous les trains qu'on a envie de prendre
donc globalement vont être plus en plus
en fait d'abonnement j'ai même trouvé en
cherchant un peu des gens qui font des
abonnements qui permettent d'accéder à
plusieurs abonnements
et du coup donc on voit de plus en plus
en fait sur à peu près tous les marchés
possibles et en fait c'est assez
intéressant de se faire le jeu de sur
tous les paiements que je vais avoir à
faire et ce qu'on pourra avoir un
abonnement pour ce qu on pourrait payer
un abonnement à rejeter que c'est pas
très légal mais payer un abonnement pour
après consommé sur un bar ce qu'on veut
pendant toute l'année donc voilà joue je
vous invite si vous voulez réfléchir un
peu au suit pas forcément à ce cas
précis mais à d'autres cas à réfléchir
un peu du coup aux différents aux
différentes façons de vraiment changer
le là comment on aborde l'acte d'achat
et ou du coup on se libère d'une
contrainte de dire je fais j'achète
j'achète pas puisque de façon on a tout
payé d'avancé et maintenant peut
consommer en fait tout ce qu'on veut
voilà merci
[Applaudissements]